hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I'm going to be giving
you the top seven Secrets the tips the
strategies that I use to get properties
discounted So Below market value
properties on High Street agents on
right move where you can negotiate the
price super low this is for people that
are looking for bargains right now in
the market or maybe you're a deal
sourcer and you're looking to find brr
properties
um discounted properties hers but you're
looking for a deal that you can then
justify a nice fat finders feon for your
investors so how do you get good
discounted properties in this market
well the first thing is this
if you're a cash buyer right now or
maybe you're not but your investor is a
cash buyer it's a massive selling point
so I would encourage you if you're
working with investors try and find
investors who are cash buyers you don't
want to be so super super rich if you've
got 100 Grand cash or you can find
properties in cheaper areas like
Stoke-on-Trent for example where houses
there's loads of houses for 100 grand
but if you're going into estate agencies
and you're saying
I'm a cash buyer or I'm working with
such a such an investor this is what
we're looking for and it'll be cash
that's huge also if you're buying
properties that are run down they're
unmortgageable so 90 of buyers that are
buying with mortgage can't buy that
particular house but you're buying cash
so it's going to open you up to a whole
new Option of properties and um that's
the first thing maybe you can't be a
cash buyer maybe you're not cash buyer
maybe you're not a deal sourcer there's
don't worry because there's another six
points number two is have a good
solicitor and have your solicitor
already lined up when you're talking to
estate agents and you're going and
looking at properties if you're just
brand new and you're clueless and you
haven't got a plan and the estate agent
it's not just about the strength sorry
it's not just about the price the
highest offer it's about the strength of
your offer so if you go into an estate
agent even if you're not catch even if
you're buying with a mortgage and you
say this is my solicitor I'm ready to
roll we can act quickly there's no no
chain I've got nothing to sell even if
someone else offers higher than you they
might accept your offer because of the
strength of your position so number one
is cash if you can that's going to get
you a big discount number two is the
strength of your offer by having a good
solicitor number three is similar and
that's how have your documents ready you
see when you put forward offer on a
property if the estate agent says offer
accepted the very first thing they're
going to want is they're going to want
your photo ID your correspondence
address your proof of funds your
solicitors details and your mortgage in
principle and they're going to want
those things pretty quick so when you go
to the estate agent
maybe you go into this agency shop or
you're on a viewing if you can tell them
you've got all that information ready
maybe even show them bring it bring your
ID and say look I've got all my
documents ready and tell if you tell an
estate agent oh here's my offer it's 70
grand I know that they want 90 but it's
a cash offer I'll be able to complete
within four weeks my solicitors ready to
roll and I've got all my documents ready
if the if the vendor says yes I've got
my photo ID I got my proof of funds I
can show you anytime I've got my
correspondence address I've got my
solicitors details that will be music to
the estate agent's ears so they might
have had a higher offer 87 from someone
who's selling a house they're in a chain
they need to get a mortgage
it could be months and months time is
money so that's number three number four
is it's a numbers game if you're trying
to get 20 below market value properties
the average property in the UK right now
is about 280 Grand so that's probably
300 to keep the match simple twenty
percent twenty that's about about 60 000
pounds so again 20 discount off a
property which happens all the time by
the way
that's 60 Grand so by you putting a
little bit of effort into finding a good
deal and getting a discounted property
you're potentially saving sixty thousand
pounds
just from your negotiation so my next
point is number four is it's a bit of a
numbers game if you want to get a good
deal don't get emotionally attached to
one property and get all excited don't
be unmotivated buyer deal with motivated
sellers put forward lots of offers if
you're not embarrassed by your offer
it's probably a little bit too high so
you know some people say I'll try
putting an offer forward I've put three
offers forward and and no one's accepted
there's no below market value deals out
there or three
so you're trying to make 60 Grand or
save 60 Grand and you think just making
three calls just gonna come on try 300.
so and you might oh that sounds like too
much well how long does it take to put
forward an offer on a property versus
how much discount you have to weigh up
how much your time is worth I'd be happy
to make it you put in a fair few calls
to get a 60 Grand discount so it's a
numbers game next tip though tip number
five is this really important
to save time
be upfront with the agent so when I ring
up an agent let's say I see a house on
the market for 150 Grand and it's worth
about 150 Grand but I'm thinking I want
to get 20 discount so I'm wanting to buy
it for what would that be that would be
uh 30 grand off so 120. I'm not just
gonna go and view it
and then put an offer of 120. I'm gonna
call the agent and I'm gonna do
something called an if would offer so an
if wood offer goes like this hey I've
just seen your property on the market I
can see it's on for 150 Grand I'm really
interested to come with you I'm a cash
buyer I've got all my sisters and
everything in place ready to roll
however just to be up front and put my
cards on the table
if I was to walk for around about 120
around the 120 Mark you know what are
you what do you think they'd say is it
worth becoming to to book a viewing I
don't want to offend anybody I don't
want to waste anyone's time but I think
I'll be looking at offering it it would
you know definitely be less than 150
what are your thoughts so what you've
done now is you've told the agent
basically that you're going to offer
about 120. now of course you're not
actually offering 120. don't try and
offer because if you say if you say this
bit wrong if you've said to the agent
I'd like to come and View and my offer
would be 120. they'll think you're an
idiot because they'll be kick in you
can't offer on a property you're not
send so you that's what you have to do
if would I don't want to offend anybody
I don't want to waste your time and you
don't you don't want to waste don't want
to go and view 10 houses with 10
different agents offer 20 below market
value and piss them all off and then
you've wasted your time you've upset
them because they have to put the offer
to the owner that's part of being an I
used to be an estate agent so if you put
forward a stupid offering then they have
to put it forward to the owner and then
the owner's like no that it's just a
waste of everyone's time and it's it's
it's it's
um it's awkward
but it's not awkward having a one minute
phone call and saying hey I see it's on
for 150. listen uh I am a cash offer I
wouldn't be able to offer the full
asking price I'd be looking around 120
of course I have to come out and have to
see the property first I just didn't
want to waste time I mean what do you
think is it worth me is it worth me
booking interviewing or not
and if they say no they've already had
offers of 140 and have said no there's
no way they'll accept that then you can
say no problem have you got anything
else
because I'm looking for a bit of a
bargain at the moment what what have you
got coming up no we haven't got anything
all right no worries we'll have yourself
a wonderful day next it's a one minute
phone call
you've not gone and viewed a property on
your lunch break so be upfront on the
phone direct that will save you a lot of
time next number six I love this one
don't just scroll right move
and wait for to see something and then
call the agent
I call this a criteria call call an
agent
with no property in mind
in fact call all the agents in your area
or the area that you're looking and tell
them you're criteria and just say hey
um you know I'm ringing you because you
seem to be one of the best estate agents
in the area and my name is Samuel
um my situation is I'm a cash buyer I've
got about 200 000 pounds I'm looking to
spend and I'm looking for something
though that is is you know I'm looking
to deal with a motivated seller I want
to move quick I want to buy cash do you
have anything where you know any of your
sellers are looking to get a quick sale
I'd be really really interested to come
over here and then they might say you
know what we've not got anything on the
moment we've not got anything on the
market at the minute but
we have got something coming up now
you're getting off Market opportunities
all they might might say we've not got
any opportunities at the moment but I
appreciate your call thank you so much
giving your details I'll call you if
anything comes up now you've got people
you're on people's books and then the
final thing Point number seven and this
is so important and this is
intrinsically linked with my code of
honor as a human being which is
honor those that helps you be loyal and
when someone does give you a deal thank
them like this is so basic but it's
soaked such a long way most of my deals
come from estate agents that I've
previously bought from because the best
way to build a relationship with an
agent is to buy from them so if you buy
from an agent and they give you a
discounted deal
go down the office once you get the keys
bring them champagne and flowers and you
know really thank them properly and be
loyal to them try not to buy from other
agents if you can don't be super
Cutthroat and be like which whoever
brings me the best deal no I want to be
loyal to this agent they help me they
gave me a deal and when they feel that
they'll be the same to you and when they
get a banger of a deal and they've got a
hundred investors they'll be like I'm
calling Samuel Leeds because he loyal to
me I'll be loyal to him there's one set
of tips hope you like them subscribe hit
like I'll see you soon